let's talk about the rules of intermittent fasting
i've done a lot of different videos on this topic
but i just wanted to condense everything in
just one video so let's take it from the top
a lot of times people want to know what can i
eat with the fast what can i drink with a fast
let's talk first about drinking water is fine
there's a thing called a dry fast that's a
whole different topic but i do recommend drinking
water tea is totally fine a certain type of teas
can help you fast longer and decrease
hunger because the herbs in tea
help support your blood sugars and your liver
coffee is fine i just wouldn't want to overdo
it but coffee will not knock you out of ketosis
because tea coffee and water have basically zero
calories so it's just the amount of calories
that could bump you out of fasting next question
is can i take certain supplements when i'm
fasting i recommend it especially vitamins
electrolytes minerals b vitamins in the form
of nutritional yeast trace minerals omega-3
fatty acids especially dha and so if you're
doing cod liver oil for example or fish oils
the calories are going to be so small
it's going to not really interfere with
your fasting ideally if you get a green drink
without the fiber let's say a wheatgrass juice
powder you're getting something that is super
concentrated usually about 6 to 11 times
less volume of material because it takes a lot
of greens to make just a little bit of juice from
that and so usually one serving when you add water
comes out to less than one gram and so you get the
boost of nutrition without messing up your fasting
what you do want to avoid is the protein powders
especially whey protein powder and there's many
other ones i would just avoid all protein powders
also avoid branch chain amino acids because
it will turn into sugar pretty quickly now
as far as bone broth there's mixed reviews some
people do find that their ketosis actually stops
for way too long and other people it doesn't seem
to affect their ability to generate ketones so
this is mixed reviews you might want to try it
out and see if you actually can do it or not
get a little testing unit to check yourself now as
far as mct oil which sometimes you're going to put
in your coffee to make it a bulletproof coffee you
can put butter in it you can just put coconut oil
or just put mct oil what's going to happen
is you're not going to lower your ketones
because those fats will turn into ketones but
the only thing that's going to happen if you do
too much of this is you're going to shift from
burning your own fat to burning this fat and
turning it into ketones now that's not necessarily
a bad thing especially in the beginning as you're
making the transition into ketosis but at some
point if you find that your weight loss is stalled
then realize it could be this extra fat that
you're consuming but i actually do recommend
it for a lot of people because it allows them to
fast longer which is actually very very important
because you want to get your body adapting and
mct oil can give your brain straight ketones so
there's some other benefits to taking mct oil so
it's kind of depends on your situation okay number
three don't eat unless you're hungry so when you
start this fast and let's say you're gonna go 18
hours and your main goal is to lose weight and you
find that you just completely have no appetite go
a little longer now you don't have to do a really
long fast right off the beginning but you're on a
roll your body is eating it's eating its own fat
it's not starving might as well ride the wave
and go a little bit longer you're going to see
better results but you want to prevent the point
of going too far where your body is weak and you
feel dizzy so you want to be able to differentiate
some slight hunger pains you're a little hungry
but you have a lot of energy and you have no
cognitive problems might as well just push through
that especially if it's in the morning at eight
o'clock in the morning where you have this spike
of cortisol where your body might be releasing
more sugar but most people just push through that
and then the hunger goes away but you've gone too
far if you're very weak and you're fatigued and
you're dizzy and you have irritability all right
number four the longer the fast the more you have
to refeed slowly so if you're fasting for 48 hours
or longer make sure you consume just a small
amount of food maybe a little egg a little
lettuce maybe a little bit of peanut butter but
not too much food too fast because what happens is
that sometimes if you do a long fast especially
if you're getting like 72 hours or even longer
and you have this huge meal your system is not
ready for it and you can really feel kind of
bloated nauseous and so i don't recommend it so
just do a little bit of food wait a little bit
have a little bit more food kind of gradually go
into it number five a good indication to know of
the severity of insulin resistance is how long can
you go without feeling like you need to eat food
if you can fast easily over a period of time that
means that you don't have much insulin resistance
left there's not a problem now
there's other good indicators too
like if you were to check your blood sugars and
let's say you're fasting your blood sugars go
up that means that you're not quite out of the
woods you have insulin resistance because your
body is actually making more sugar it's called
gluconeogenesis because of certain mixed messages
with insulin connecting to the liver and so if you
can't fast for a very long time all that means is
you have insulin resistance and you have to just
keep working on it you have to give it more time
add more fat to the meal too which will make
you more satisfied and allow you to go longer
number six i recommend you always do keto with
intermittent fasting i mean think about you're
getting all these great benefits with fasting why
wouldn't you also want to get the benefits from
keto which is also going to keep your insulin
low when you eat if you're fasting and then you
go to a high carb diet you're going to raise
insulin raise your blood sugars and kind of
minimize the effects of intermittent fasting all
right number seven i recommend you do periodic
prolonged fasting why because longer fasts give
you additional benefits there are three really
important benefits that most people get with
just regular fasting not that long maybe 16 hours
they'll lose weight they'll have cognitive
benefits memory focus and concentration
and they have mood benefits they
go from anxiety or depression
up to a higher level of emotion they just feel
better a calm sense of well-being which is huge
but when you do periodic prolonged fasting you
really support your brain you grow new brain cells
when you run your body on ketones there's much
less free radical damage there's much less
waste products being generated as compared to
running your body in glucose where you have a
lot more free radical damage and so ketones are
more efficient fuel it's less stress on your body
it creates less waste and more oxygen and less
co2 so it's it's good brain food also you're
going to support your immune system you're
going to be able to fight infections better
you're going to actually increase your resistance
of your cell from toxins you'll decrease your risk
from cancer because one of the
purposes of your immune system is to
kill cancer cells this is a good benefit right
and then you have the anti-aging benefits because
your body is recycling old damaged tissue and
definitely proteins so you're cleaning up these
cells that are dysfunctional and you're renewing
them so for repair and regeneration and anti-aging
doing a prolonged fast here and there is
definitely worth it all right thanks for watching
before you go if you have a question about a
product or you're new to keto and you want to
know how to begin keto or you're on keto and you
need a debug because it's not going as smooth
i have a keto consultant standing by to help you
this is just for the people in the u.s. hopefully in
the future we'll be able to answer everyone's call
but i put the number down below
so you can call and get some help